all right let's hear from some people in
the audience I want to start today with
Josh from Delaware we take calls via
Discord at davidpackman.com Discord Josh
welcome what is on your mind today
hey David can you hear me yes I can
awesome uh first time caller glad to be
here
um yeah so definitely wanted to talk
about last week
um I know one of the big things that
gets talked about a lot of is the
election lies
um and you know I do have some friends
that always talk about a legend was
stolen it was stolen there's so much
evidence but where is the evidence
um just kind of I wanted to hear from
you on uh has anyone ever sent you
anything just showcasing any evidence of
electric fraud at all no the I mean many
people all the way up to Mike pillow
have said as soon as we get off this
interview I'm going to send you all the
evidence from my cyber guys or whatever
they've never sent any evidence at all
sometimes they will send me a link to
that Dinesh D'Souza Movie 2000 mules but
of course even that doesn't have any
evidence it just has video of people
dropping off that ballots at dropboxes
with ominous music playing and some
geolocation data that doesn't actually
prove anything and you know the I I'm
willing to work forwards which is show
me the evidence from which I can draw a
conclusion if and if the conclusion is
that the election was stolen by Joe
Biden I will tell you after this many
years of claims with no evidence I'm
starting to wonder whether maybe the
evidence doesn't exist Josh
thank you David and I have one more
follow-up question pretty quick
um but Fox News
um you know I know one of the other
things has always been the uh pretty
recently the text messages that were
sent privately between the Fox News host
especially with Tucker Carlson yeah kind
of your thoughts on that
how can people still watch Fox News
after that information was released and
I also got to say I don't remember
Tucker even denouncing that those
messages weren't even him so how can
people still watch Fox News and uh
believe that's still a good news
organization to get their uh their daily
news from primarily the answer is that
Tucker's viewers either will never hear
about the text messages in which Tucker
says he despises Trump or they will
explain it away by saying well Tucker
had to say that for this reason or that
reason but he didn't really mean it or
they will say he has since changed his
mind they'll explain it away one way or
the other they seem pretty committed at
this point to Tucker into Fox News
got it well thanks David appreciate your
time and hope you have a good rest your
day pleasure there is Josh from Delaware
very very much appreciate that remember
to ideally get right to your question
and I love that everybody's got their
correct audio devices selected today
when you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below